it's game night at campanelli stadium in
brockton massachusetts
[Music]
home of the brockton rocks
along with the typical minor league
antics
fans are flocking to the park about 25
miles south of boston for a chance to
grab an autograph from these guys i have
manny's pedros
he's not talking about retired red sox
slugger manny ramirez or former ace and
hall of fame pitcher pedro martinez he's
talking about their sons it's the best
thing coming here because you could you
could go over three with three
strikeouts and the fans still love it
just 19 years old and on his way to
junior college in florida this fall
manny ramirez jr is treated like a
celebrity in brockton despite an injury
that will keep him out the rest of the
season this is like something that only
happens like once in a lifetime so it's
amazing to see manny jr is playing
alongside childhood friends deangelo
ortiz and pedro martinez jr back in 2004
their legendary fathers manny ramirez
david big poppy ortiz and pedro martinez
helped bring boston its first world
series title in 86 years honestly it
feels like a movie i'm not gonna lie to
you like it feels so fake like wait wait
this is happening
the one two martinez jr who's 21 was the
first to join the rocks it sounds
planned but it really was not
i showed up here last year and i was
only one i ended up coming back and boom
we got a whole new dance crew that crew
also includes his cousin jose pedro
senior's nephew and son of former l.a
dodgers pitcher ramon martinez jaden
sheffield son of nine-time all-star gary
sheffield and kade folk whose father
keith closed out the red sox historic
2004 world series win
i think of your dad in the final out do
you have a moment where you remember
first seeing that i just really remember
a picture of us together on the field
after world series and it was me crying
and i'm in his arms it's just kind of
something i've grown up with jose what
is the best thing about having a dad who
has been a major league player the
knowledge that it comes with
he just knows exactly the right steps to
take what i got to do and he's just a
great partner what's the hardest thing
the expectations
the expectations is to a whole different
level
inside the dads have all spent time
around the club this season offering
tips and sharing stories from their time
at the pinnacle of the sport this is
what you do when you're a hazmat out
here push dirt around when we visited
folk was giving the grounds crew a hand
how has it been for you
to help groom not just your son but some
of your former teammates sons as well
yeah it's been incredible being a big
league ballplayer is great but there's a
lot of struggles involved if we can make
a young athlete's path a little bit
easier makes him a little bit wiser on
the field and off the field you know
that's that's kind of being that mentor
and we take pride in that even though
you're short the kids say there are also
ups and downs to having their dads
hanging around so much it's really fun
but it also sucks a lot you know he
really helps me you know with every
aspect of the game but at the same time
he's pretty much always on my case you
know the other day like i had kate's dad
try to help me work on some like thrown
motions and i had manny's dad come and
help me in the cage and he kind of saw
some things that my dad
was trying to explain to me and wasn't
articulating in a way that i understood
when it's your dad still yeah even no
matter how great your dad is right
sometimes you don't like to listen
because it's your dad
these potential next generation baseball
stars don't expect special treatment but
they found comfort in teammates who know
exactly what they're going through what
really keeps it like human is the fact
that we can make jokes about it just
keep it very normal because we're people
and the goal the same for all of you to
make it to the major leagues not just
get there but like actually do something
maintain it yeah
learn to stay not just show up and then
leave for cbs morning's dana jacobson
brockton massachusetts
i want to go watch them play right hey
the next generation
i love uh what one of them said you know
the knowledge is great that's passed
down oh yeah but the expectations that's
the worst part big goal i love that they
admitted hearing advice from their own
father is tough they'll take it from
somebody else's that's every child
exactly sorry every child still exactly
adam a t special shout out feature
producers here on the show terrific
producer just left us recently just a
shout out well done nice piece
really nice